À quelques kilomètres
de Genève, en Suisse,
se cache un autre artisan
qui ne compte pas ses heures.
Charles Roulin est un coutelier
unique au monde.
Mes mains pour moi,
c'est vraiment très précieux.
Très souvent,
quand je commence une pièce,
dans ma tête, je me dis "je vais avoir
de la peine à y arriver."
Et puis en fait...
Avec mes grosses mains...
Ça marche, j'y arrive !
Sa renommée, il la doit à des scènes
animalières en trois dimensions,
qu'il sculpte sur des lames
en acier trempé.
Ce sont deux pièces terminées.
Là, c'est une scène avec un ours,
qui est un peu affamé
et qui veut manger un élan.
Ça arrive !
Ça, c'est de l'ivoire
de mammouth, qui a 40000 ans.
C'est toujours quelque chose de...
de fantastique, quand on touche
ces matériaux en se disant,
que c'est une bête qui galopait
à travers la nature il y a 40000 ans.
Ça, c'est un peu le même principe.
Un couteau droit
avec une scène de chasse.
Qu'est ce que ça représente pour
vous les couteaux Charles ?
Pour moi, c'est un coup de foudre.
Le vrai coup de foudre !
Parce qu'il dure depuis 30 ans.
Les rares coups de foudre
que j'ai eu avec les femmes,
ils n'ont jamais duré aussi longtemps !
Aujourd'hui, les couteaux de Charles
sont convoités dans le monde entier.
Il faut patienter en moyenne
trois ans pour en acquérir un.
Je dis toujours que c'est
du travail de fou pour des fous.
C'est du travail de fou.
Passer des heures et des heures
et des heures là-dessus.
Et puis, il faut être
assez fou pour les acheter.
Parce que certains couteaux,
coûtent quand même le prix
d'une jolie petite voiture.
Aujourd'hui, justement, Charles doit livrer
sa dernière œuvre à un collectionneur.
- Salut mon grand !
- Ça va ?
En plein de forme !
J'ai amené ton couteau.
Ce grand collectionneur possède
plus de 200 couteaux,
dont une dizaine de Charles,
ses pièces maîtresses.
L'Africain,
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a une vie.
Il y a un troupeau qui bouge, qui se déplace...
Avec la protection des adultes
qui protègent le petit au milieu.
C'est maintenant le moment
de découvrir sa dernière acquisition.
Un couteau inspiré du peintre Gauguin.
Et des îles Marquises.
C'est le rappel du tableau
avec les vahinés,
dans le paysage des flamants.
Enfin non, des vieux !
C'est ce que je dis toujours aussi.
Les couteaux de Charles ont une âme.
À un Noël, j'étais seul à la maison.
J'avais un coup de blues.
J'ai été chercher un de
ces couteaux et c'était l'Africain.
Et là, j'ai pris l'Africain,
j'ai commencé à jouer avec la lumière
et puis avec ma loupe.
Et j'ai eu cette impression, sans avoir
fumé de cigarettes qui font rire,
de rentrer dans le paysage.
J'avais presque peur de faire du bruit
pour que les animaux ne m'entendent pas.
C'était assez extraordinaire.
Et c'est vrai que
ce sont des moments qui sont...
Quelqu'un qui n'est pas intéressé par
la coutellerie et par ce côté artistique,
ne peut pas comprendre,
mais ça vaut la peine d'essayer.
Quand j'entends ça, pour moi,
mon travail est réussi, tu vois ?
Parce que...
C'est même émouvant.
Mais à 80 ans, Charles reste
un homme de défis.
Après deux ans d'hésitation, il vient
d'accepter une commande exceptionnelle.
Un client chinois
passionné de mythologie,
lui a commandé un couteau avec
pas moins de 9 dragons qui s'entremêlent,
sur le manche et la lame.
Je n'ai encore jamais
fait de dragon chinois.
Quand je vois la tête qu'ils ont,
je me dit que je ne suis
pas sorti de l'auberge.
Ils ont des moustaches,
ils ont des cornes,
des crêtes sur le dos
et plein d'écailles.
J'avoue franchement
que ça fait presque deux ans,
qu'il me la commandait,
et j'ai toujours hésité.
Ça va être un des plus durs ?
Oui, je pense que ça va être
un des plus durs,
mais qu'il sortira bien.
Mais j'ai quand même... Un peu...
L'angoisse.
Pour réaliser cette pièce
d'orfèvrerie si complexe,
Charles s'est donné deux mois.
Un défi à la hauteur de sa réputation,
de meilleur coutelier du monde.
Hugo, c'est un petit garçon
de treize ans,
révolté et un jour,
sa maman m'a appelé parce qu'elle avait
vu qu'Hugo s'intéressait à la coutellerie.
Souvent, elle le voyait en train
de regarder mon site.
Et puis Hugo, quand il est venu ici,
il me plaisait bien ce petit.
Je lui ai fait un petit chantage.
Je lui ai dit que je le prendrais volontiers,
pour lui apprendre
ce que je pourrais lui apprendre,
mais qu'avant il fallait
qu'il remonte un peu ses notes,
qui étaient un véritable désastre.
La proposition de Charles
a eu son effet.
Salut Hugo ! Ça va ?
En quelques semaines, Hugo, le petit rebelle,
a remonté toutes ses notes.
Hugo, là, c'est celui que tu avais
mis en forme la dernière fois.
Je ne sais pas si tu veux encore
changer un petit peu la forme.
C'est comme tu veux.
Après, on va commencer l'émouture.
Hugo, qu'est-ce que tu aimes ici ?
J'aime le fait que ce soit fait
de A à Z, dans le même atelier.
Par la même personne.
Ça, ça me plaît. C'est beau !
Avec Charles, Hugo réalise
son premier couteau d'apprenti.
Je te laisse faire.
C'est étroit. Pardon.
Reste bien sur toute la largeur.
De nouveau, tu étais légèrement comme ça,
donc tu travaillais qu'avec l'angle.
Pendant que Hugo poursuit
l'affutage de sa lame,
Charles entame une étape cruciale
dans la fabrication de son couteau.
Sur cette pièce,
ces fameux neuf dragons.
On vient de donner le coup d'envoi,
à un bon mois et demi,
si ce n'est pas deux de travail.
Il va maintenant creuser directement
dans la masse du titane.
Le métal le plus dur au monde.
Pour cela, il dispose
de fraises de précision.
Les plus grosses que j'ai.
Habituellement utilisées
dans l'industrie.
Il y en a des quantités ici.
Ce sont des fraises au carbure de tungstène,
qui sont beaucoup plus dures.
Des fraises en acier rapide
comme le dentiste,
dans de l'acier comme ça,
elles tournent cinq secondes,
et puis elles n'ont plus de lames,
elles sont foutues.
Tout comme celui d'Hugo, son apprenti.
Qu'allez-vous chercher là, Charles ?
On va essayer de trouver
un joli morceau de bois,
pour faire le manche du couteau d'Hugo.
Oui, c'est chouette quand même !
Il faudra le finir encore un peu là.
Faire un peu d'herbe,
affiner un peu les branches.
On va regarder un peu par là.
Entre le maître et son disciple,
la complicité est installée.
Il n'y a qu'un tronc là,
ce n'est pas un gros morceau.
Attends, on va aller vers là.
Ça, c'est du buis.
Par contre, c'est un très beau bois,
Un bois très dur.
On va le garder celui-là.
Il faut le garder et le scier
à la maison pour voir.
Dans ces bois, Hugo,
tu penses qu'il y en a un qui
peut marcher pour ton couteau ?
J'aime bien le buis, parce que
c'est un bois plutôt clair,
C'est nickel !
De retour chez Charles,
Hugo va être le premier
à découvrir son chef-d'œuvre.
Est-ce que tu pourrais me montrer
le couteau avec les dragons ?
Le résultat est impressionnant.
Ça, c'est le premier flanc.
Les neuf dragons ont été sculptés
directement dans le titane.
Ça, c'est la lame avec un dragon en 3D.
Elle est magnifique !
Ça, ça représente deux mois de boulot.
Avant d'expédier le couteau au client,
il reste une ultime étape.
Là, ce sera la partie la plus délicate.
Quand tu enlèves de la matière,
tu ne peux pas la rajouter.
À l'aide d'un microscope
qui grossit 35 fois,
Charles va devoir graver des détails
de quelques millimètres,
directement sur les vis du couteau.
Un détail d'un 10ᵉ ou même
de 2 ou 3/10 de millimètre,
il est vite parti avec une fraise
ou même avec ce genre,
de caoutchouc.
Une nouvelle fois, la main de Charles
n'a pas tremblé.
Formidable !
C'est fini,
comme je dis toujours,
de la barre d'acier
au coup de chiffon final.
C'est toujours moi
qui ai la main dessus,
et il a un léger clic en plus.
Mais pour finir,
il a quand même fière allure.
Voilà, encore un bébé qui s'en va.
Charles rédige maintenant
le certificat du couteau.
Il est garanti à vie.
Flan en titane,
de neuf dragons en médaille.
Les neuf dragons vont être expédiés
à l'autre bout du monde,
à un riche homme d'affaires chinois.
À 80 ans, Charles vient de réaliser
son plus bel ouvrage.
Pour Charles Roulin, en Suisse,
la relève est assurée.
Il a la grande chance, à quatorze ans,
de découvrir cela.
Moi, j'ai découvert ça à 49 ans,
donc il a 49 ans d'avance sur moi !